uh Darcy I've got to ask you
um I understand that Georgie may or may
not be here right what's going on uh
George is a little apprehensive about
coming to the tell-all today and he
wants to go into real estate so he's
taking classes three days a week
to get his license so you know today he
will be studying for that Darcy this is
such a big day for you and your sister
talks about it at one point thought he
was going to he was like you know 70 30.
and so he's in New York he's in New York
he came but um
you know maybe he just doesn't want to
get triggered by things
I'm just
shocked that he chose not to show up
it's okay for him to come to New York
stay in the hotel
but not support her on stage this is a
big deal for us and
I feel like
it's a red flag to what's to come
I think at times he thinks we're gonna
like judge him or gang up on him or
something which is not the case
this is the man that you want to spend
the rest of your life with absolutely it
would be nice to have Georgie by my side
to feel protected and um honored and
loved
how about can we try to call him now I'm
open to it I'll try it you know see
we'll see what happens can we get uh
Darcy's phone
so she can try to call Georgie
so that's mine
you know
all right
one second let me see let's try but I
feel like he's gonna be
in a mood
I'm in for it
you shouldn't have to feel like that
relaxed you see on the defense all the
time is it is what it is
hey babe
hey it's me um here on stage with Sean
and Stacy
so I understand where you're coming from
but you know it'd be nice to have you by
my side just to feel loved and protected
as well
are you talking about I'm not there to
be
support from what
you're growing up I don't need to be
there to support you you're growing up
your family is there they're gonna
support you you don't need them there to
support you actually I need support from
you right now with emotional stuff and I
don't want to be there with other people
there's like uh
I have more is more stuff to do in my
life I don't care about these people
this is stupid
come on grow up I'm not happy I'm not
happy with uh
how he's talking to my daughter
[Music]